hey everyone i'm excited to give you a
sneak peek at the upcoming avatar
reckoning in this mmorpg shooter you'll
return to the moon of pandora to find
your own way in the aftermath of the
battle of the hallelujah mountains
as you begin your adventure you'll
customize your own avatar warrior you'll
also be able to collect and customize a
range of weapons to prepare you for your
journey
as you set out across single-player
missions you'll discover new regents as
you unravel a mysterious story
encountering new clans and defending
yourself from the perils of pandora from
creatures to the rda forces you'll also
be able to play both with and against
others in online multiplayer team up in
instances to battle with other players
trying to survive against powerful
enemies for battle in player versus
player mode where you'll team up against
other players across a variety of maps
you'll be able to experience all of this
and more when avatar reckoning hits your
mobile device soon